I am so excited to introduce our next
guest I am so thrilled that she is here
she is a philanthropist a un messenger
of peace mother award-winning actor who
is currently right now in one of the top
Netflix films of all times the Old Guard
ladies and gentlemen it's Charlize
Theron
oh
I'm probably gonna have to redo the
intro because of my lifelong lisp I'm
like Netflix is the the best friend it's
the best thing on Netflix
you better not touch that that is what
we love about you so do not touch that
whenever I see someone parody me which
I'm always like so excited that I anyone
would even know who I am let alone
parody me it's always like the you know
the craziest face and the list and I'm
just like dying laughing I'm like it's
true
oh my God the way you just did that face
that's amazing if someone was gonna do
you they would just get taller and more
beautiful and more like worldly and
philanthropic and smart
it's true that's not true once I did
monster everything I did after that they
were like oh another Ugly movie another
Ugly movie
and and SNL did a skit where literally
it was just like me walking around like
trying to like look like a baby's arm
growing out of my head was trying to be
as uncomfortable looking as possible and
I was like guys I did one movie like
that stop it we have a friend in common
um and you even mentioned this in your
Oscar speech this man Steve Warren yes I
remember I said my lawyer Steve Warren I
heard this like snickering in the
audience like wait you can't thank your
lawyer and I was like he's my friend
he's amazing and I don't have to tell
you this I mean he's changed my life I
I've I think all of the beautiful things
that I have in my life today Steve
somehow has something to do with it we
actually have something in common too
which is I've heard you're like on you
know a break from relationships and yeah
I'm so in love with my children I have
this love in my life that's so impactful
and I've spent my life trying to figure
out men for 45 years I'm like I'm tired
I'm bored it's all about the kids
yeah yeah I I completely know what
you're saying and it is strange for
people to kind of wrap their heads
around it I've been on a few like dates
but I haven't dated anybody
um for over five years
um me too yeah so we have a lot in
common so I mean I'm open when friends
of mine are like you should go on a date
we're like you should meet this guy like
I'm always open but it is like I feel
like I'm in a place in my life where
you got to come with a lot of game like
not not the kind of game that we think
of the kind of game that's like my life
is really good so you better like be
able to bring that and maybe better
because I just won't accept anything
less and my life with my children and
with my incredible adopted family that I
have around me I I don't long for that
much I don't really I don't I I can
honestly say this on my life
I don't feel lonely once I had my
children it it's not that it replaces
something or that it makes you less
interested in something else like I'm
still like I was just two seconds ago
talking about a dude that I thought was
really hot like I like I'm still firing
in all cylinders I just
I think your priorities are in a place
that is of high demand right because
it's it's it's a lot of work to be a
parent and then part of that is at the
end of the day I get in bed and I go my
God I wouldn't want this day to be
anything different yeah I always say I
would want someone to be an addition if
not the equation and never a subtraction
that's you said it I did the poor man's
the uh the line of that thank you for
I'm gonna take that I'm stealing that
just so you know it's for both of us
since we're both on such a similar path
and Jackson is eight yes and August is
five
yes
I have Olive who's eight this month and
Frankie who's six
wow we're so close I know I never
realized our kids were that like aligned
in ages yes super super close I had an
idea we were close but I didn't know we
were that close oh well gosh darn the
pandemic I would be like how are we
getting our kids together when things
ease up I would love nothing more I I
yeah
oh please I and my kids they you know
it's so hard for kids with uh the
adjustments and and God bless all of
them for being as adaptable and sane as
some of them are I I just I I it makes
me Marvel at their capacity and
adaptability how are your kids right now
my mind is blown by that as well I have
to tell you
you know there's a part of all of this
that's so devastating right like we are
really truly living in a whole new world
and when I look at my children and how
they're just adapting to it so well this
you know just the idea like the other
day I walked out of the house and I had
to walk back into the house because I
forgot my mask and I realized my
children don't forget their masks they
literally always have their masks on
them I'm like I'm the one that always
like I walk out I've got to go back in
and get they have just embraced that
this is what their world is right now
and I I have to say like even the
homeschooling like when we went into
that first lockdown it was really really
hard because they're kids right and so
they just don't fully comprehend but by
now they figured out okay this is what
it is and it's like it's really
different like they've kind of embraced
this now and they they still you know
can share that they miss their friends
and that they miss going to school but
at the same time they're just not
dwelling on it which is just so
incredible it's like they're just moving
on with it
foreign